[Music]
so uh this clip totally blew me away
personal trainer shoe have hung is in
his gym showing off the power of his
lungs with a homemade blow duct does
this guy have superhero lungs remember
drinking and blow darts are never a good
mix so please don't try this at home or
at the bar
so does shoe have super-powered lungs or
super-powered science knowledge she
wasn't using a conventional Dart he's
using an iron nail which is eight times
lighter than a conventional dart she's
wrapped
card around the back of the nail so it
makes a nice seal inside his tube when
he sharply blows down the pipe it
creates some pressure which has nowhere
to go forcing the nail down the length
accelerating it all the way because the
darts so late there isn't as much mass
to accelerate so the pressure that Xiu
creates when he blows on it it
translates to more speed at the end of
the blowgun the long length of shoes
pipe means the nail is given more time
to accelerate giving it a higher exit
speed as the nail leaves the end of the
pipe is traveling at 22 miles per hour
or 36 km/h giving it enough force to be
able to smash through a bottle well
that's just super